attention brad and jen stance we know
you haven't given up hope on this once
a-list couple
right babe yeah we fell for brad pitt
and jennifer aniston when they first
started dating in 1998 that fandom only
ramping up when they married in 2000 and
became a certified pop culture
phenomenon brad even did an episode of
friends
hi
will right right right hi i'm rachel
green oh i remember you cut to five
years later though and they called it
quits but fast forward to 2022 both brad
and jen are single again so will they
rekindle their romance oh it's so worth
the wait well a source just told e.t
brad and jen are still friends they talk
and have a nice friendly cordial
relationship good stuff though yes it is
but don't get your hopes up for a return
to the bliss of the early odds
yeah you probably guessed our source
says they aren't getting back together
but they have a lot of respect for each
other what do i do with it what do i do
with that information now and that
shouldn't come as too much of a surprise
that mutual respect was on full display
in 2020 while the former couple made the
rounds during awards season brad was
doing his victory lap across red carpets
for once upon a time in hollywood my
name's cliff
i'm rick dalton stunt double while jen
was being shown the love for her role as
alex levy in the morning show my sex
life is about to get a whole lot better
and they just couldn't help but escape
the obvious the second most important
reunion of her year
yes with brad and jen in the same room a
reunion seemed inevitable and at the
screen actors guild awards that year
fans got the moment they've been waiting
for backstage brad sag statue in hand
came face to face with jen brad taking
jen by the hand smiling at each other
jen placing her hand on his arm and then
on his chest as brad takes her hand in
his once again it was the moment that
sent fans reeling and fueled speculation
that they still had feelings for each
other but it seems it's as close as
we'll get to brad and jen 2.0 awards
season has been so fun
what do you make of our reaction to the
big reunion backstage last week at the
set i don't know i'm blissfully naive
and i'm gonna stay that way okay you
haven't been on the internet at all nope
[Music]
you